un nuevo gabinete para la presidenta en
funciones de Perú será paritario y
destaca el nuevo Primer Ministro es el
abogado Alberto otárola quien ejercía
como ministro de defensa un nombramiento
criticado por congresistas de izquierda
pues lo culpan de las más de 20 muertes
que han dejado varios días de protestas
no voy a darle la confianza a un
gabinete que de nuevo no tiene nada que
solo
representa puro y que carga sobre sus
hombros 27 muertes en sus primeras
intervenciones o tarola arremetió contra
el gobierno de México pidiendo al
presidente López Obrador que deje de
referirse a los asuntos internos del
país suramericano amlo Aunque descartó
romper relaciones fue muy crítico esto
después de que Perú declarase persona no
grata al embajador mexicano y pidiera su
salida del país lamentar
la decisión que tomó
el gobierno
de
Perú
Un gobierno muy cuestionado por la
represión
las relaciones pasan por un momento
difícil y la familia del expresidente
Pedro Castillo ya ha llegado a México
bajo asilo político después de tratar de
disolver El Congreso Castillo fue
destituido y encarcelado un 85% de los
peruanos pide nuevas elecciones y el
congreso aprobó un proyecto para
adelantarlas a abril de 2024 Pero hay
quienes piden que sean antes 32 millones
de peruanos están pidiendo que haga
elecciones en seis meses o cuatro o seis
meses a lo mucho son muchos los que
siguen exigiendo la renuncia de Dina
boluarte y la liberación de Castillo la
presidenta ha asegurado que se mantendrá
firme en el cargo por lo que la crisis
peruana no parece que cederá pronto